before we get to the music man first of
all congratulations on married life
thank you very much married life has
been great yeah so far and I'm really
lucky that she also gets to travel with
me out on the road a lot yeah you guys
look like you're having just the time of
your life you know what we are and I
married a good one she has the best
personality in the sweetest heart so I
got lucky and a great family as well is
it true that your wedding was planned in
just a number of month like four months
yeah it was it was really fast like we
got engaged on Father's Day and got
married in October that's why yeah
wasting no time wasted no Tom had a
great wedding planner that really helped
out a lot but my wife Lauren she did a
ton herself and I kind of just stayed on
the golf course was it always the plan
to to share your wedding with everybody
in your big big plans video you know
what no even before I got engaged I had
no idea I was even gonna use a song to
do it or to ask her it kind of just
happened organically I was in the room
riding one day and this song came about
and then we we never finished it though
we only wrote a verse and course and the
more I listen to it the more I thought
there could be something to this song so
then we get back together with the
riders and we finished a second verse
and still didn't finish the third verse
which is the verse that I used to
propose and then the third time we got
back together to finish this song I told
them about my plans to propose to her
and like the next two or three months
and maybe it would be cool to throw a
proposal in there write it in there and
that's exactly how it happened and then
yeah I used some of my wedding footage
to go for the music video as well
raising the bar man making a heart fries
write songs brother for yeah yeah yeah
and I mean we get to your reaction when
you propose what was the reaction of of
the family all around to the
even that you were gonna do that her
parents were very excited I was actually
in Portland Oregon where where my wife's
from and I was with her parents for
roughly eight hours by myself she had to
go do something during the day and that
was the time that I asked them for her
hand and then told them my plans of what
I wanted to do and I was just because my
touring schedule was so crazy I was like
there's only a couple of specific dates
that I can do it but I'd like to do it
in her hometown just like I wrote in the
song and it just so happened to be
Father's Day I asked her dad I'm like
look I would never want to take away
from your special day and he said you
know what I would love for you to do it
that would make this day even better so
I planned it out like that and it worked
out and yeah I'm just glad she said yeah
and you're and now you're out on the
road you know if you look online for
tickets to show sorry it's all sold out
okay you're just sold out man must feel
so good it does you never know as a
young artist what to expect when you
decide to go out and do a headlining
tour and it's a little nerve-wracking
because I was out with Brad Paisley all
year long last year I did a short run of
headlining shows and it all went really
well so I was hopeful for this run but
it's been better than I could have ever
imagined yeah
are you learning or changing or growing
at each stop like is very there's
something you take away from every show
yeah I think it's just for me I've been
lucky enough to go out on tour with a
you know Florida Georgia line and like I
said I was out with Brad Paisley I was
out with Rascal Flatts and so many more
people and what I took away from
watching them perform every night was
they didn't really
they basically just went out there and
had a good time didn't take themselves
too seriously and I think for me on this
tour it was one of those things don't go
out there and overthink anything just
have fun and hopefully people walk away
saying man I had fun at that show I want
to go again when you're working with
acts like that do you do you get advice
from them or is the advice more just
watching house yeah I think the advice
is basically just watching how they
operate I mean they've all been crazy
successful and and you know I'm hoping
that I can one day have a career like
that and have one that long so yeah I
think a lot of times I learned just
through emulation or watching other
people do their thing and taking away
what I can and what I feel like is would
be a great additive to my show what's
the pressure like for you I mean big big
plans is huge 65 plus million streams
when you see numbers like that you go oh
man the next one's got to be yeah yeah I
think from the beginning for my first
song fix to I don't know about you and
now big big plans I don't know about you
my last single was the biggest song of
my career and I'm very thankful for that
song but yeah you always want to try to
outdo the last song that you had and
yeah this songs off to a really good
start and I'm very excited about it and
I had no intentions on a releasing it
and B I had no idea it would end up
being a single either
so there he goes fortuitous right
absolutely now there are some bachelor
fans that got a cool little uh I guess
Easter Egg from watching God know about
you video Hannah and you're cooler than
that is yes and the batch did you know
that you see that you know what I
haven't even seen but I did I've seen a
bunch of tweets saying where do I know
Hannah am from oh yes from I'm Chris
legs I don't know about you music video
so yeah I'm sure that's very exciting
for her as well to be a part of The
Bachelor yeah she got I think she kind
of liked the first impression rose oh
really oh that's awesome
does that doesn't surprise you guys it
no you know what she was really great on
set yeah all day long very professional
and really good at what she's doing so
yeah
yeah I can imagine that she's gonna be
great on the show that's amazing
now you were just on the phone with your
lovely wife this once thought that she's
not with you on but you you bring her on
with you quite a bit right yeah which is
very helpful for our relationship
because you know she has the kind of job
where she can pretty much travel
whenever she wants as long as she
doesn't have her own thing for that
weekend so I get to bring her out quite
a bit and we get to bring our dog out on
the road as well which is yeah Cooper
comes with us and it's really good now I
have two buses before it was crazy
because she was riding around with 12
dudes on one bus and she also had to
sleep in a bunk which was which is which
is really hard on her but but now I have
my own bus yeah I got a big bed in the
back and that's gonna make things way
easier yeah fun to be able to bring her
along with you yeah you know what what I
truly love a lot is the fact that the
country music community has really has
really welcomed her and every single
show that she's out and I'm playing the
crowd will chant her name until I bring
her out which is it's so sweet for me I
love it very much
okay so I know your fans would probably
really curious asking all over social
media you know you got married what's
the next step are you guys are you guys
planning and family is that in your big
big plans yeah you know what we don't
know when that will happen
we're definitely open to it we just want
to make sure that the timings right I'm
gone a lot so we would a lot of it would
fall on her yeah at the end the day we
both definitely want kids we just bought
a home that we can grow into and had
every plan of buying that in hopes of
having kids at some point but yeah for
right now we don't know when that'll be
we're we're just enjoying practice